bonjour je lis à garnier merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
sur les fuites sortie dans la presse le
chef de l'état pourrait donc décider
dans le prolongement du confinement peut
être jusqu'à la mi-mai et peut-être
également de la fermeture des écoles
jusqu'en septembre
est ce que vous y êtes favorable qu'est
ce que vous attendez exactement du
discours ce soir d'emmanuel macron ce
qu'on attend c'est une vision
stratégique et savoir vers où on va et
comment on y va c'est à dire que la
question des masques la question des
tests
la question de la planification
sanitaire est une question cruciale et
déjà nous avons déposé avec la france à
sony une proposition de nationalisation
des entreprises qui sont stratégiques
pour cette planification sanitaire
notamment je pense à lui serge pour ceci
afin marque qui fabrique des médicaments
qui fabrique des bouteilles d'oxygène
dont on sait qu'il a besoin
emma comment est ce que on va organiser
la production pour sortir de cette crise
parce que il faut bien se rendre compte
que sans masque en test à grande échelle
les crânes d'oeuf
mais c'est pas possible donc il va
falloir répondre à ces questions là qui
sont des questions pratiques
on ne veut pas de grands discours on
veut de l'action lors de l'un de ses
discours emmanuel macron a dit que ce
n'est pas le moment de faire des
polémiques
vous qui critiquait sa gestion de crise
la france insoumise
qu'est ce que vous lui répondez c'est
pas une question de pognon
monsieur macro prend des décisions
politiques et nous en tant que politique
nous sommes là justement pour les
discuter et ce n'est pas une question
d'opposition abstraire pour se poser
c'est une question de vision
aujourd'hui nous ne sommes pas en guerre
nous sommes sommes en crise et en tant
que crime
nous devons avoir les moyens justement
des de réfléchir à l'organisation
politique que prend le pays et cette
organisation politique eh ben elle n'est
pas divine elle se critique et elle se
construit et nous sommes là justement
pour dire faisons des propositions
politiques organisons c'est ça que vous
faisons ou ce sont des propositions très
concrètes
la nationalisation dont je viens de vous
parler en est une nous en avons d'autres
est également pouvoir organiser le
déconfinement parce que derrière il n'y
a pas que le confinement il ya aussi la
vision du monde d'après qui se pose est
ce monde d'après d'envoi bien
certains au gouvernement le prépare déjà
et la façon dont ils le préparent ne
nous plaisent pas par exemple quand on a
le medef où la secrétaire d'état à
l'économie qui déjà la bourre les
esprits en disant eh bien vous allez
travailler plus que vous allez faire des
efforts et vous allez vous asseoir sur
les congés payés ou sur les jours fériés
cetera
eh ben ce n'est pas une vision qui nous
contenter et que nous pouvons accepter
justement vous parlez du medef
le medef et la cfdt s'oppose sur le
temps de travail post confinement pour
relancer l'économie du pays qu'est ce
que vous proposez vous à la france un
soumises lors de cette période post
crise
ce qu'on voit c'est que il demande aux
français de faire des efforts toujours
aux mêmes de faire des efforts mais je
rappelle qu'en ce moment même il y à des
entreprises françaises qui versent des
dividendes
vous avez par exemple vivant dit qui va
qui va servir près de 700 millions de
dividendes ou encore veolia ou encore
michelin etc
on va pas tous les citer mais on voit
que de l'argent il y en a et que à
chaque fois quand il s'agit de richesses
elles sont privatisées et quand il faut
faire payer tout le monde est bien là on
pense aux travailleurs c'est toujours le
même refrain et cela les gens ne sont
pas dupes
ce qu'il faut c'est vraiment qu'ils
changent leurs habitudes de rentiers
c'est à eux de changer et ce n'est pas
aux gens de changer
aujourd'hui il faut penser à ne pas
relancer l'économie telle qu'elle est
mais la relance et de manière différente
penser différemment
vous savez en 2017 on avait proposé une
vision alternative des choses pas
s'appeler ça avait un programme c'était
l'avenir en commun ce n'est pas un bout
de papier
j'étais une vision des choses quand on
parlait de relocalisation quand on
parlait de planification écologique de
partage des richesses et ben vous aviez
là dans des mesures qui étaient
importantes et par exemple je n'en
citerai qu'une demo proposions de
recruter 62500 soignants 62500 soignants
et c'était pour un coût de 3 milliards 3
milliards e s'en sont servis pour la
supprimer l' isf nous on s'en serait
servi et bien pour donner plus de
soignants aux gens et on voit bien que
ça on en manque cruellement aujourd'hui
donc vous voyez bien qu'il y a deux
visions qui s'affrontent il y à leur
vision qui est toujours le libéralisme
est de toujours mettre à profit et de
capter des richesses pour le 1 %
eh bien nous nous pensons que c'est en
mettant dans les richesses dans le 99%
que l'on pourra s'en sortir en mettant
en commun les services publics etc
vous parlez de
visions différentes
damien abad le président du groupe l'est
républicain l'assemblée nationale
souhaite créer une commission d' enquête
à l'automne pour tirer les leçons de la
crise du cornât virus vous également
critiqué le gouvernement sur la gestion
de crise on a l'impression finalement
malgré ces deux visions opposées que la
droite et la gauche sont au diapason
pour critiquer l'action gouvernementale
oui alors je mets quand même rude défi
certaines personnes de critiquer une
action qu'il il y a quelques années
soutenue largement je rappelle que la
suppression des lits dans les hôpitaux
ça date pas d'hier et on a même la
commission européenne qui a demandé près
de soixante trois fois quand même aux
états de réduire leurs dépenses de santé
donc il faut quand même se garder de
nouveaux convertis qui tous d'un seul
coup peut-être par opportunisme
remarque les erreurs qu'ils ont fait
mais en attendant si vraiment ils sont
conscients des erreurs s'ils sont
conscients de la faillite du système
tu me mêle dans cette situation là alors
général invite déjà à regarder l'avenir
en commun et puis surtout à réfléchir à
une autre vision de l'économie une
vision d'économies qui nous mais comme
je le dis dans une planification parce
que les gens se voient bien que et ben
l'intérêt aujourd'hui c'est pas de
construire des voitures c'est pas de
relancer le transport aérien aujourd'hui
c'est de relancer ce qui compte vraiment
qui compte vraiment eh bien on le voit
ce sont ces soignants
ce sont ces postiers ce sont ces
cheminots ce sont ces c'est bien soudé
les enseignants etc
qui est ce on voit bien que ce sont eux
qui sont en première ligne donc ce qu'il
faut rémunérer si vraiment il faut faire
passer quelques jours dans premier et
ben ce sont tous ces services publics
bien avant le club al c'est mona fin
merci julie garnier d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
oratrice
nationale la france a soumises